the path leads high into the rugged
mountains of eastern albania
and 1500 years back into history
to a tiny chapel
art restorer gentian stratoberde and
orthodox priest yaniranja come up here
often
early this year they made a shocking and
tragic discovery
that's right the icon's head is missing
the vandals tried to hack the frescoes
off the walls of the shan prem to chapel
with axes and knives
they were the work of the renowned 16th
century icon painter onufri
the guards were laid off a year and a
half before for lack of funding
none of our cultural treasures are
guarded
over the past 20 years countless
churches have been plundered
this is just one example
even worse the police tried to hush the
matter up they didn't come here from
tirana for three days and only under
pressure from us
they just looked around and took off
again and two weeks later there was
another break-in and more frescoes were
stolen
and destroyed rather than apart nuclear
the institute of cultural monuments in
the capital tirana is trying to save
what it can
piecing together what was left behind
and yet the institute director apologe
does not believe the authorities could
have done any more to protect the
cultural treasures in the first place
there's no clear jurisdiction here
unfortunately
we've got five or six agencies that
share responsibility
the police the church the conservation
authority the ministry
all of them share responsibility and
nobody's responsible
many albanians realize that and in
spring a group of conservationists
demonstrated in front of the ministry of
culture
accusing institute director bache and
other agencies of indifference and
corruption
some of the results of what he terms the
government's negligence
in the city of duress for example is the
largest preserved roman amphitheater in
the balkans
dating back to the second century but
the city let developers build villas
right on top of it
now he says they're destabilizing the
amphitheater
after the fall of communism we started
on a systematic destruction of our
cultural heritage
unfortunately our worst enemies aren't
the thieves and vandals
but the very institutions that are
charged with protecting these treasures
tara and some volunteers are taking it
upon themselves to stop the destruction
both on land and
underwater plunderers have even raided
archaeological sites in the adriatic sea
one of the kingpins in the antiquities
racket is the golden dawn a far
right wing party in greece
an orthodox priest calls believers to
worship
the greek extremists haven't been here
yet or they would have scraped off all
the faces in the frescoes
trying to make it look like the work of
muslims as some experts claim
gentian stratuberda is hoping the newly
elected government will make good on its
promises to protect albania's cultural
treasures